- Everyone has an opinion.
You know, and you know what?
I don't have a problem with that.
- As a matter of fact,
everyone has so much opinion, Gash,
that I literally think
if I put a tattoo on my face,
it would be two cents.
(laughs)
Like literally that
would be a '2' and a 'c'
with like the two cents
because literally,
everybody's got two cents on everybody.
- Yeah.
- Brrr, brrr!
♪ Movin' it quick ♪
♪ Tryin' to get rich ♪
♪ Got hit in an Uber they call me a Lyft ♪
♪ What it is what it is what it is ♪
♪ Girl I'm stuck up in my ways yeah ♪
♪ Get the, fuck, outta, my, face ♪
(hip hop music)
♪ My heart goin' up and down ♪
♪ When it's you I see ♪
♪ All these girls so salty ♪
♪ 'Cause you're so sweet ♪
♪ You ain't the one that I want ♪
♪ You don't want ♪
♪ Tellin' your friends ♪
♪ That you're really not in love with me ♪
♪ You can keep on frontin' ♪
♪ But I know ♪
- I ain't gon' lie.
I been kinda blastin' this kid's shit.
- [AOL Man] Goodbye.
(explosion)
- I say all the time,
hate wins halftime,
- [Gashi] Yeah.
- And love wins the fourth quarter.
- Exactly.
Man.
- You know, that's why
I just think about life that way.
So many people judge it.
Shit like your music career!
Can't judge it yet!
- It's just startin', man.
- It's just starting but the reality is
and you know this, and
you definitely know this,
and you definitely,
like, one album, two albums, a record,
people are judging like it's over,
or you made it.
It goes both ways!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- One hit wonders first song out
- Yeah.
- Plenty people start
covering, business, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- The amount of people
with first song out,
one hit wonders,
that was the best thing
they ever did was a lie!
- Yeah.
- There's a lot more of
those than people realize.
- Man, it sucks.
Especially like men,
everyone has an opinion, you know?
And you know what?
I don't have a problem with that
- As a matter of fact,
every has so much of opinion, Gash,
that I literally think if
I put a tattoo on my face
it would be two cents.
(laughs)
Literally that would be a '2' and a 'c'
with the two cents,
because literally
everybody's got two cents
on everybody,
- Yeah.
- And I, my big thing and the reason
I think I'm gonna win
the whole fuckin' thing
is I just don't hear it.
- Yeah.
- I'm being serious.
And it goes both ways.
- Yeah.
- Literally in my comments or
people talking,
two people having dinner,
one thing's G.O.A.T. and
one thing's full of shit.
- Yeah.
- I read it every day.
- It's true, I mean,
you know what, bro?
I was watching this thing the other day
randomly, I'm on YouTube all the time,
and I was watching, 'cause
I love documentaries
- [Gary] Me too.
- Some random shit popped
up and it was like,
Britain's worst attitude,
you know that show, Britian's
something, whatever?
And there was this dude
with an attitude, whatever,
who comes on stage and
he's cursing everyone
I watch Kelly Rowland telling him
she said, whatever, this is corny
but what she said was really cool.
She said,
- By the way, I love her.
- Yeah I've never met her.
- I've never met her too,
I talk to her all the time
- Yeah yeah.
- On social, but I don't
- Yeah she said to him, she goes,
'cause the guy's cursing the fans out.
She was like, you see how everyone has
an opinion in this room?
This is the business you signed up.
This the game.
And if you can't handle that,
this is not for you, you lost.
- It's so funny, I posted
yesterday, I'm like, look,
if you're losing, that's your fault.
- Yeah.
You can't point the finger
and blame anyone else.
- Because if you're like
'oh the game is rigged',
it means you didn't figure out how to
figure out the game.
- Yeah.
You gotta play the game.
- In the music game
it's all the same shit!
People are like, 'ah, fuck
playlists on Spotify!'
I'm like, you mean, radio stations?
You mean MTV?
(laughs)
You mean The Source?
You mean Dick Clark?
You mean Ed Sullivan?
There's always a platform!
- Yeah.
- Elvis and The Beatles
figured out it was Ed Sullivan!
Madonna and Prince figured out it was MTV!
So did Puff Daddy later with TRL!
The motherfucker ran into
Carson's studio every day!
- That's crazy.
- [Gary] Like, if you don't understand
Instagram and Snapchat and
Soundcloud and Spotify,
then you're not fuckin' gonna win!
- True, it's very true.
- Like, sorry!
- 100 percent.
- If you don't understand
getting your music
into vloggers and fuckin'
if you don't like that,
if you think that's bobo
or bullshit or wack?
Cool!
Then you're out!
- It's true.
(laughs)
You know what I'm sayin'?
I just feel like a person
that really wants it
will find a way.
- [Gary] 100 percent
and people that say,
'I'm not gonna sell out',
no no, you mean that
you're insecure for real
and you're not willing
to do what it takes.
- Yeah.
- That's what I hear,
when people are like,
I'm not gonna sell out.
I'm like, what does that mean?
'Cause selling out means
you're taking a dollar.
- That's not selling out.
- So if you're not selling out,
that means you're going for free.
That means you're gonna be Gandhi.
So don't talk to me about
you're gonna be a musician
and not sell out.
- Yeah.
- Course you're gonna sell out.
You take one fuckin' dollar,
you sold the fuck out.
- That's true.
- What you're saying actually is
the system isn't putting you on
and you're not good enough
to win in the current system.
So you wanna shit on mumble rap?
Cool, you wanna sit on fuckin' cosigns?
Cool, you wanna shit on Soundcloud?
Cool but guess what?
- And you're alone.
Yeah it's true.
- [Gary] And by the way,
if you can do it so well,
if you can be the
biggest act in the world,
if you can do it your way,
do it your way!
- Yeah, yeah.
- But my big thing is like, show me.
Results are results.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, honestly bro,
it's been almost 10 years now for me,
coming into the game.
You know how it work,
I don't know if you know too much,
but it's crazy.
Coming to this country was crazy enough.
I was born in Libya,
and I traveled 24 countries to get here.
When we came here, we were in a shelter.
My father and my whole family,
my dad worked at a
synagogue, two synagogues.
We found a way to live as a
in a building,
one bedroom apartment, all five of us
for like, so long.
You know what I'm saying?
- I do know this and
I don't know if you know,
that's so much of my story as well.
- Yeah he was tellin' me that!
- I was, I got out of Soviet Union
for political asylum for being Jewish.
- Wow I ain't know that!
- We moved to Belarus, to Austria,
- Wow.
- Austria to Italy,
Italy to America
- Sounds like my story!
That's crazy, I lived
in all those countries.
- HIAS was the Jewish foundation
that got us out.
Could be the same one as you.
- That's crazy.
- I went to those same places,
I lived in Queens in a studio apartment
with eight family members
- Wow!
- My great-grandfather,
when he came to America had 88 bucks,
he went directly to the synagogue
and gave it all to them
because he couldn't practice religion
in the Soviet Union for 50 fuckin' years.
- That's crazy.
That's crazy, that's very similar to me,
so then you do understand.
And in the music business,
I went to school, I dropped out of school,
I had a full scholarship to play football,
I dropped out
- [Gary] Where, to where?
- I went to a school
in Massachusetts, AIC.
- [Gary] I love it.
- Yeah, and I left.
After I left, I was like,
what do I now?
So I had my friends, Mike
and Dave help me out.
And they were like,
yo, let's just do the
music thing, whatever.
So I dropped out.
And then next thing you know,
the CD didn't take off as I expected it
- [Gary] Of course.
- And my parents were like,
either get a job or go back to school,
I'm not letting you live in the house.
So I found myself in the
New York City streets
sellin' my CD with a big ass jacket on
and just keep pushin' and then
I had a job at Billabong
and that shit was trash
and then I got fired.
And then when I got fired,
I took my last check and I was like,
this is gonna be
- [Gary] This is it.
- This is it, this my last check,
either I record my last song, stop music,
go back to school 'cause my
parents weren't havin' it,
or I just cop those Jordan 3's
and get ready for college.
So, no joke,
I went and recorded my last song,
it was a song called Who Made Me
and I put it out, whatever, and then
- How'd you put it out?
- I just put it out on YouTube.
- [Gary] That's what I wanna know.
- No joke, dude,
it didn't change-change my life
but it was funny 'cause
that Sunday night,
me and my mother were together
and I was supposed to go Monday
and register for school,
it came on on the radio.
The same song.
It came on on the radio,
while I'm driving my moms to work.
- [Gary] Get the fuck out
- Yeah!
Fuckin' Rosenberg played it.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
It was a sign for me not to quit.
(laughs)
Know what I mean?
And I felt like that was a sign,
so I pulled over, I started crying.
My mom started crying for me.
She was so happy for me.
I was like, I'm not goin' back to school.
And she was like, what do you mean?
I said, I'm not goin' back.
I was like, this is a sign.
I gotta keep goin'.
- I love it.
- And then, next thing you know
- You better, when you
fuckin' win that Grammy,
you better be like, 'Rosenberg!'
- Yeah I need to give him a shout out!
- You do, you do, you have to!
You have to!
- I mean there's so many people
that have helped me
- Of course but he deserves it!
- Yeah definitely!
I'm 'bout to see him today!
- You better fuckin'
kiss him on the mouth!
(laughs)
I'm serious, man!
I believe in that shit.
- Yeah, yeah, for a fact, man,
and that changed everything.
'Cause I was like,
alright, I'm not gon' quit.
I put it out, put another song
and I got signed to Jason F
and I signed for like $5,000 dollars.
- [Gary] Of course!
(laughs)
- I ain't read the contract
which was stupid, make sure
you're on your lawyers.
I went to Aspen, Colorado and
I thought I was on, man.
I thought I was on.
- [Gary] Right, you made it.
- I thought I made it,
'cause I was in Aspen.
- You know what's so funny
about the music world
for me?
It's so similar to the VC world
that I came up in,
investing.
So many kids celebrate when
they get their funding.
- Yeah.
- There's a really interesting clip.
I was at a Bloomberg show,
and it was like a competition show
and you know how MTV, Road Rules
they bring everybody back?
So it was like a bring back show
and they were all there
like six months later.
And teams would go around and be like,
'And since the show, we
raised $2 million dollars.'
And the crowd would go crazy.
And then one team was like,
'yeah so we didn't raise any money,
'we just started getting customers,
'and we're doing okay!
'It's working!'
Silence.
I lost my shit.
I was like, this is why
this whole thing's fucked!
We're clapping for people
who haven't done shit
but they raised some money.
- Yeah.
- Aka they gave up a
piece of their business,
and control.
- Yeah.
- One team fuckin' is
grinding and making money,
and none of you got love for them!
I'm like, fuck this!
It's the same way I think about signing.
All these kids think when
they sign, they did it!
- Yeah.
- Poppin' champagne, their boys,
you did it, you didn't do shit!
- Yeah, yeah.
- Nine out of 10 times,
you signed a dick contract.
- Yeah.
- That's gonna take you four years
to get the fuck out of,
if God forbid, something good happens.
- Oh my God.
- 99 percent of you are
gonna put out shit music
that nobody's ever
gonna give a fuck about.
(laughs)
So we need to, in the culture completely,
we need to, in the culture
of the music industry,
start realizing the day you get signed is
an important milestone,
I don't wanna shit on people's parades
- [Gashi] Yeah yeah yeah
- But let's contextualize it.
- Like you,
only, don't sign unless
you're super fucking lit.
And you know what?
- [Gary] Have the leverage.
- Yeah have the leverage
and you're going in there
because yo bro, I signed
for $5,000 dollars!
It was the worst deal ever,
I couldn't get out of it.
And then next thing you know, man,
I'm like, struggling,
struggling, struggling
and my girl at the time goes,
come to the club, just chill
out, get your mind off.
Whatever, I go to the club on 14th,
and I walk in, waiting on the line,
the kid grabs my jacket and goes,
'oh my God!
'I'm a huge fan, I just
heard you on the radio,
'I sing too!'
And I said, cool, bro.
And I go inside the club, I come out.
I see him again.
And he's like, yo man,
I'm really a singer,
I'm gon' be on the TV show
Dancing With The Stars,
I sing, I was like, alright, cool.
And then, next thing you know,
I connected that person with Jason F
and I asked Jason F to drop me so
I got him that artist, and I swapped out,
and got out of my deal,
flew out to L.A.
Started working working working.
- [Gary] That's crazy.
- Nothing happened for me.
That whole week in L.A.,
I did like 10 songs.
I used all those songs for my album
and on top of that,
I worked on DJ Snakes' album
which was like my come up, my first spark.
But still, I wasn't on.
I was on a album with Beiber,
Skrillex, Travis Scott, Quavo.
I was on a song with
Travis Scott and Quavo
on DJ Snake's album.
I lit two big songs on that album
and I was still home doing nothing.
I got in trouble with the cops,
(Gary laughs)
I got in trouble with the law.
See this is what happens when
you have a lot of time on your hands.
I got in trouble in Brooklyn, and
- Still wanna send all these fuckers
to garage sales and thrift stores
and just flip and make money.
I'm not joking, I'm obsessed right now
with getting people to flip.
- [Gashi] Yeah, yeah.
- I think to your point, sitting around
is trouble in two ways.
There's people who are from the streets
and will really get in trouble.
- Yeah.
- Like, the cops.
And then there's people in trouble
and they don't realize
they're in trouble, aka
they're watching six hours of Netflix and
playing 2K.
- Yeah, yeah
- They're in 'trouble',
they just don't know they're in trouble.
So I'm pushing everybody like,
yo, go to the fuckin' thrift store,
buy a t shirt for a dollar,
post it on eBay and make $20.
Fall in love with flipping.
- That's what my friend does actually,
that's crazy, it's true.
- I'm a big fan of that
'cause it keeps you busy.
- He sells toys, too.
- Look!
Who you think you're talking to?
- That's crazy.
- I used to buy Captain
for 25 cents and sell it
for eight bucks on eBay
and be happy as fuck!
- Yeah.
That's crazy.
- The thrill of the hunt!
- That's crazy.
- The thrill of the hunt.
Anyway, you got in trouble.
- I ended up getting the warrants.
I went to Iceland, and
did a show in Iceland,
got money, went to L.A.,
and then, bro, I couldn't come back here,
so I did a song Disrespectful
and bro, that's when my life changed!
I got invited to do a session
- So literally the warrant
forced you to be in this place
where you
- And then the case got dropped!
The case got dropped, I fly back,
this is how I actually made it.
This is how I got on, I'll
tell you this right now.
This is what changed my life.
I went to L.A., I didn't
want to do the sessions,
I thought those two kids were like,
whatever, corny, I ain't wanna do it.
And I was like, fuck it.
And then I'm driving, I get a text,
'are you coming to the session?'
I forgot about the session.
But I had to take a shit,
and at the time, I was like yo,
I don't got no one or no friends here,
I'm 'bout to just go take
a shit and just chill!
So I went
- [Gary] You literally had to take a shit
- I had to take a shit and I was hungry so
'cause I'm always goin'
into people's fridges
at the time, I had nothing.
So I go and I'm driving
my friend Rorie's Prius,
I go and I'm like
- Fuck it, I can shit and get a burger
- Get a burger, whatever
- Banana, whatever the fuck they have.
- And I swear they knocked on the door
like, 'yo, hello?
'Yo are you ready?'
'Cause I was in the bathroom
for like 30 minutes,
on the phone, using their wi-fi.
(laughs)
Takin' a shit, and I was just
they were like, yo,
are you ready?
And I was like, fuck, I
forgot to do the session!
So I jump in the booth and I freestyle.
And I come out, I leave, peace, we out.
Get the song.
Song's dope.
My sister calls me,
case got dropped.
Fuck yeah.
I hop on the plane
- [Gary] Changed your whole shit.
- Yeah, changed my mind, now I'm focused.
I come to New York, I
see my sister and my mom
played them the record,
they're, 'so what you been doing in L.A.?
'how is music going?'
I'm like, yo, it's cool,
I did this song, boom.
I played it, I'm turning it up.
And I'm dancing to the song.
And my mom and my sister
are going, yeah yeah yeah!
Recorded me.
- [Gary] Wait a minute.
- And I posted it on Instagram,
and I had 300 thousand fucking views
and 600 comments!
In like such a short amount of time!
And I was like what the fuck?
That's never happened to me before.
So I'm like alright, cool,
and I get a call and my boy's like,
'you wanna perform?
'Queens, come to Queens tomorrow night.'
So I'm like, a'ight, fuck it, let's do it,
I need the bag.
So I go, and next thing you know, dude,
my DJ plays it, the last song,
he plays that song, it
hasn't even dropped!
And everyone says,
get the fuck outta my face!
And they're singing the
song from the Instagram!
And that's when I knew,
yo, this shit's a fuckin' banger!
I put it out, bro, I put it out,
shit hit like 20 million.
And it kept going up and going up.
Got meetings, and you know it's crazy
I ended up signing with Roc Nation!
But even before then,
Jay-Z threw my mixtape in the garbage!
- [Gary] Of course!
He throws every, he throws 99, he has to!
- [Gashi] I know.
He doesn't have time!
- [Gashi] I'm not mad at him.
- I know you're not mad at him.
He's got no time!
It's not personal, it's reality!
- But it's like amazing
the fact that he did.
- Dude he's thrown mixtapes in the garbage
of the people that have gone
and become the biggest stars in the world!
You don't think over the last 10 years,
every fucking rapper has tried to
put their mixtape into Jay-Z's hands
before they went and sold out stadiums?
You know how many things I passed on?
I didn't even answer the Airbnb email!
I didn't even answer the Airbnb email.
'Dear Gary, we want you
to invest in Airbnb.'
If I answer that email and give $25K,
I'd make $100 million.
Didn't even answer it.
I passed on Uber twice.
Would've made $400 million.
Fuck music, it happens everywhere!
- That's crazy.
- [Gary] That's the game.
- Yeah, you know, yeah, it sucks.
- Guess what?
If you didn't have to take that shit,
you wouldn't be sitting here right now!
- Exactly!
It's true!
- People don't get it!
People don't get it.
This is why, when everybody gets mad at me
saying to rappers, 'put out more music',
Gary V, you always say the
same shit to everybody,
'cause it's fuckin' true!
- [Gashi] Yeah.
You never know!
- You're one piece of content away
from every single thing changing,
and people are sitting
around in their living rooms
and their basements and garage
and with their boys and being like,
ah that's not a banger.
So you mean,
you're just not gonna put it out?
You mean to tell me
that you saved up, worked
at fuckin' Foot Locker,
saved up, took the fuckin' subway,
saved up, went into fuckin' studio,
paid some half-assed
producer to do something,
saved up, and then you and
your three fuckface friends
are just gonna sit there and be like,
ah it's not good enough,
we're not gonna put it out?
What the fuck's the matter with you?!
- Yeah that's OD.
- [Gary] My guy, that's
what everybody does.
- It sucks.
- That's what every
single one of you does.
- [Gashi] It's wack.
- Put the fuckin' music,
if you made it, put it out!
- [Gashi] Yeah.
- You know why I let
them record everything?
'Cause it's me!
- Yeah.
- Good?
Cool.
Dumb?
Great?
Cool, two fuckin' sets.
- Yeah.
- I don't care.
And if musicians didn't care,
and realized, I,
musicians, artists are insecure by nature.
- [Gashi] Yeah.
- So you made something,
and then you fuckin'
critique your own shit,
and you shit on it
before anybody heard it!
The whole system's broken
and now we got the internet.
This isn't about having to get signed,
printing fucking shit on cassettes
or physical devices,
having the Virgin megastore.
That world is over!
- Yeah.
- You fuckin', clip, Instagram, boom,
game over!
- Game over.
- What do you think happened to Beiber?
What do you think happened to Lil Yachty?
What the fuck is everybody doing here?
Do people understand what's happening?
The answer's no.
Especially in the music industry.
Put out the fuckin' music.
- [Gashi] I agree.
- The end.
- I feel like I've had so many chances,
so many lives in the business.
So many lives, you always
have lives in this business.
- [Gary] Couldn't agree more, man.
- 2 Chainz, 2 Chainz is a good example.
- Tity Boi was Tity Boi!
People don't know!
- I know!
- Tell us about your
Young And Unhappy tracks.
- Oh shit, I'm putting that out!
That's crazy that you asked that,
I'm putting that out.
Can I get a water?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I'm putting that out actually today.
- [Man] Today?
- Yeah that's crazy.
So I did this song called
We Are Too Young To Be Unhappy.
- [Gary] Truth.
- I just feel like
- [Gary] First quarter!
- Yeah, I do a lot of drugs,
you know what I'm sayin'?
And I cut off on it because
I'm slowly, I get anxiety,
I got anxiety right now,
you know what I'm sayin'?
But I try to keep it cool.
But I just feel like
- But hacking at why
instead of using band-aids is the game.
- [Gashi] Yeah.
- Everybody's doing all sorts of things
for anxiety, depression,
things of that nature,
and that's like putting a band-aid on it,
versus attacking why.
And that's why two cents matters to me.
Because when I think about why,
it has a whole lot to do
with other people's voices.
- Yeah.
A lot of reasons why.
- [Gary] Of course!
- I just feel like, man,
you know, man,
I have a lot going on, man.
I have, my whole family on me
- [Gary] Other people's voices.
- Yeah man, I got people to feed, man.
- [Gary] Other people's voices, my guy.
- So I got a lot of shit to take care of.
- Guess what?
That's the fucking game.
You know how Kelly Rowland said?
That's the game of life.
Fuck the music.
- And you know what, man?
Sometimes it becomes stressful,
sometimes it becomes too much.
- [Gary] For everyone.
For everyone.
There's nobody walking
around saying 'cool.'
- Exactly.
- [Gary] And everybody
deals with it different.
- 100 percent.
- The best part
to your point is the evolution.
Fuck yesterday.
Fuck how you dealt with it yesterday.
- [Gashi] Yeah.
- What about today and tomorrow, right?
- [Gashi] Yeah exactly.
- That's the power of that conversation.
- And I've gotten so
good at controlling it.
You understand?
- [Gary] Of course!
- I hate elevators, you know what I mean?
I hate them.
And I called my album Stairs
because my life has been stairs.
Because it's like, life is stairs because
thank you so much.
Because it's so easy going down
but it's so hard going up.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Gary] Yep.
- The elevator's broken, you
come from a grocery store
with your bags,
you mind walking up,
but you don't mind walking down.
And that's what life is,
life is stairs to me
because it's so fucking hard going up.
It's so easy
- So funny for me.
I'm so reverse of it, Gash,
yeah man, I really love eatin' shit.
I swear to God.
As a matter of fact, I sabotage myself
I love, this is why I
keep thinking about this,
this is why these conversations
are so fun for me.
- Yeah.
- I fuckin',
man, I wish people loved eatin' shit
and bein' hated on like I do.
- I mean,
- And I'm not saying I got answers or
I'm trying to hack too!
We're all trying to hack!
So I record everything,
maybe one day by accident,
I got something for somebody.
Boy, do I love
Boy do I love walkin',
I want the elevator broken every time.
I get excited.
- You guys have a similar
outlook on YouTube comments.
- Him and I?
Yeah definitely, bro.
I love it though, you
know what I'm sayin'?
I've gotten to a point
where I love everything
that's coming at me.
- [Gary] 'Cause it's valuable.
- Because it's amazing!
- I'm glad they even have thoughts.
When people are like,
'ah I hate,
'Gary how do you deal with all the
'negative comments?'
I'll look at the person,
and I'm funny, I'll look, two minutes.
I'm like, this person
gets 800 positive comments
that you're gorgeous, or you're smart
or your music's amazing,
and gets three bad ones.
Or 19 bad ones and 800 good and I'm like,
- Yeah
- How do I deal with the hate?
Easily!
I feel bad for the
person leaving the hate!
I'm glad that they're
even paying attention.
- Yeah.
- I'm glad they're even paying attention,
and if they're leaving hate,
where I go is like, fuck,
man, I hope they're okay
because if you have time to go on YouTube
and shit on somebody else's life,
your life's fucked.
- Your life's trash!
And every time I do click on the person
leaving a hate comment,
they have the shittiest outfit on.
(laughs)
You know what I'm sayin'?
It's like, yo, why are you
even talking to me, dog?
- It's beyond that, man,
when I click on 'em, 'cause I look too,
you can see the negativity and depression
and the dark and the anger across all
- But it's really love, you know that!
- Of course!
And by the way, if you reply,
that negativity goes
into love in 14 seconds.
- I got proof!
I got screenshots!
- I wrote a whole book about it in 2011
called Thank You Economy!
- Oh my God, I need that.
- That is the thesis.
- I need that!
- We'll give it to you,
can we tell the team to find one?
It's the thesis.
- That's so funny!
That's hilarious.
- That's what it's all about, man.
You know what, man?
That's so dope because you know what?
I didn't know too much about you.
- [Gary] Yep.
- You know what I mean?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- 'Cause I'm so focused
- [Gary] You're on your shit, I get it.
- But I've always seen your face,
and I've always seen you around
and I'm always hitting you up on DM
- [Gary] Yeah yeah yeah yep.
- And it's just amazing to have to
sit down with you and kinda
have this connection now,
you know what I'm sayin'?
- [Gary] Nice.
Me too.
- Because I can actually
relate to you,
and I feel like, out of
everyone that I've met,
in this business, whatever, in this world
that's in the circle,
I think
- [Gary] We have a similar
- You're the only one
that I could relate to,
in any way.
'Cause everyone's like,
I was born on this block
and then I just went down the street.
You know what I'm saying?
And it's like, okay, cool.
And then, that's amazing
to hear somebody say
yeah I lived here, here, here,
I had to get here and here.
And it's like whoa, alright, cool.
- For the same reason.
Persecution, people don't get it.
- I think that's what makes us go so hard.
- 100 percent!
Both my grandfathers
spent 10 years in jail
for being Jewish!
- [Gashi] That's crazy.
- Real shit.
So you know,
listen, I think it's a
big advantage for me.
Not most White people can
if you're an American,
you're not gonna
understand that framework.
By the way, I didn't live it.
So I'm not even gonna go there but
it's in the DNA of my life.
- Yeah.
- It's the structure.
I lived in a household that was Soviet.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The reason I tell nobody to complain
is I've never heard my
parents complaint about shit.
I'm fucking foreign to complaining!
I watched my parents have nothing
and never have a peep of complaining.
- So you're like,
- [Gary] I'm just like, what the fuck
you're complaining that
Starbucks gave you the wrong milk?
(laughs)
- I'm in line, and they're like,
'what the fuck?!
'I asked for skim milk!'
I'm like, I'm gonna fucking kill you.
(laughs)
I'm gonna walk over right now
and kill you because this is
ludicrous shit!
Or like, I missed the train!
- Yeah.
- Cool, the next one's coming.
(laughs)
- Stop complaining.
- [Gary] Stop complaining!
- Yeah.
I like
- Dude, complaining is like
I'm all on it now,
if you're cryin', it's your fault!
- [Gashi] I agree.
- I have a million,
my whole life is problems.
I have 900 employees,
I have a big company, it's all problems!
- But that's because it goes back to me
telling you the Jay-Z story.
He looked at me and he said,
what's your name?
I was on the line with Decoded.
He put out the book,
and then I was like,
I bought, I got the book
I took a dollar off everybody online
and hopped in the line, bought the book
and I get there,
I put my mixtape in there,
he goes, 'yo what's up?
'Ha ha, what's your name?'
I said, Gashi.
And he goes, 'dope!'
Signs it, grabs my mixtape,
throws it in the garbage,
goes 'have a good day!'
And I grab it and I'm smilin',
but I'm tearin',
and I'm walking back to the train,
happy as fuck that he touched the CD
and threw it out in the garbage!
And if I were to complain and say,
fuck this, fuck that, and be angry
- [Gary] That's what everybody does, Gash.
- I would have never signed
to him, eight years later.
- And for me,
the chemicals in my body go like this.
If that happened to me, and
I've had my versions of it,
my chemicals go in a very funny place
which is, yo I got so
much respect for Hov',
but I'm gonna fuckin' kill him.
I get crazy.
In a good way!
- Yeah.
- I have empathy for Hov',
I'm like, that's his
life, that makes sense.
- Yeah.
- Comma, my whole life's about commas.
- Comma, motherfucker.
I'm gonna make a song
that's gonna be downloaded
10 billion times,
and in that song,
I'm gonna make a reference to this moment.
Fuck you.
That's how I get!
- Yeah.
I didn't take it that far.
(laughs)
I didn't take it there.
- By the way, that's the point.
The point is, everybody's
gonna do shit different.
But the only thing that's not acceptable
is crying about it.
- Yeah, 100 percent.
I was so happy.
And you need to understand at the time,
I was super young too.
- Of course!
- And I was still excited,
damn I wish, did I do something wrong?
But not understanding, eight years later,
I don't take CDs!
- Of course!
- You know what I'm sayin'?
- Everybody's entitled,
everybody's hoping,
everybody's wishing, everybody
thinks they're special,
and it's all right.
Comma, then have respect
to the other thing too!
- Yeah.
But I ended up being friends,
we ended up working.
And it's like, damn, if I would have
ruined that relationship,
got on Twitter and started bitchin',
that would have just
made the process worse.
It's like saying things like,
ah I can't wait anymore, I'm quitting,
as if quitting makes the
- [Gary] Like anybody gives a fuck.
Just to save time for everybody because
you might use it,
cool.
- [Gashi] Yeah.
Quitting does not speed the process.
- Tweet it!
I'm quitting, fuck you, fuck the world.
I'm not from this life.
Nice.
- Have a good day.
- Who's gonna care?
Your mother and your sister?
Cool, bounce.
What?
Nobody gives a fuck!
- Yeah, life goes on!
People are dying and shit,
and we're still moving on!
- The greatest, Michael Jackson dies!
And then 24 hours we give love and
maybe get a week if
you're an all time legend.
Nobody's talking about John McCain today.
Nobody's talking about David Bowie today.
Nobody's talking about Prince today.
Prince!
In today's world, you get
48 hours on social media
if you're an all-time!
And then everybody's back
to their fuckin' life.
- [Gashi] That fuckin' sucks.
- No it's actually beautiful.
- 'Cause I love Prince, man.
- I love Prince too, man.
Little Red Corvette is my jam for life.
- That's crazy, I got a
song on my album called
Little Red Ferrari!
- [Gary] That's amazing!
That's crazy!
- That's crazy!
- Gash, it's amazing.
Because then all of a sudden,
once you realize that nobody gives a fuck,
it's liberating!
'Cause what that really gets you to is
two cents.
If nobody's gonna give
a fuck when you die,
why the fuck you worrying
about their opinions
while you're alive?
- [Gashi] Exactly.
It's true.
- It's very true.
- Yeah.
- And you know what
happens when that happens?
Everything becomes light.
You know how you felt when you heard
the case was dropped?
When you can get to the switch of
being empathetic, and
respecting everybody's opinion,
and not hearing it,
then you start going fast.
- That's what's been happening.
- Then you can give love to everyone.
Then you can be the bigger
man in every situation,
which comes around eight years later.
Boopboopboop
- That's where I'm at
right now.
That's exactly where I'm at right now,
I stopped giving a fuck.
It worked.
- And respecting it.
Some people take not giving a fuck
as like a negative, I
think it's a positive!
I don't give a fuck,
that doesn't mean you're bad or I'm great,
it's just a framework!
- [Gashi] Yeah.
Gotta keep it movin', man!
- That's what's up.
(hip hop music)
- It's Monday to Monday!
- Monday to Monday.
- Monday to Monday, you know what it is.
- The hustle don't stop
from Monday to Monday.
- Monday to Monday.
- Yo what's up everybody?
My name Young Gunna.
Monday to Monday.
(hip hop music)